try four weeks of The Spectator
absolutely free and for this month only
you'll receive a spectator Wireless
phone charger go to WWE taco UK forward
slash charger
welcome to a rather unusual issue of the
spectator broadcast throughout lockdown
were asking a relatives to read some of
what they've written for the magazine we
had thought we'd do this for two or
three weeks in the middle be back to
work it seems as if lockdown is going to
be with us for a while in one shape or
another first of all we have Frederic
Eriksson who's reading his cover story
about what lockdown is looking like and
the routes out of lockdown is looking
like in Europe we have James Forsythe
who's talking about how the government
really is going to be rewiring itself
after this is finished and least a rough
night who has a book being published
right now about the book launch party
which isn't first of all Frederic
Erikson last week Europe started its
liberation from lockdown and it all
feels like a study in national political
identity Belgium took its first step
towards D confinement but no one seems
exactly sure what that means
France is open for complexity rather
than simplicity Italy's national plan
for easing its lockdown is more
convoluted still but few regions
bothered to follow it anyway
Spain goes a national joke went more
slowly and started with a reopening of
the siesta and in Germany everyone is
praising the country's scientific
approach to the pandemic but as soon as
they were allowed to roam freely again
many Germans headed for the big audience
government say their approach is guided
by the science in reality science
doesn't offer any clear way out of this
mess there is no vaccine around the
corner no answers even two basic
questions how the virus spreads how many
have been affected while children seem
immune politics not science decides the
path out of lockdown each country is
reopening one step at a time and its own
way searching for what works in practice
given the lack of certainty Europe with
all its variety has become a laboratory
experiment in how to end lock downs here
in Sweden the experiment has involved
not looking down at all but instead
asking people to socially distance
gatherings of fewer than 50 are loud as
so sports events for young people church
services and dinner parties continue the
distancing has left many our street as
empty as Britons though and our economy
has suffered we too have a scandal of
too many deaths in care homes algis and
as with everywhere else it's not much
more than a guess is that we're seeing
the tail end of it our deaths are about
average for Europe Oh bite higher than
the rest of Scandinavia the virus has
spread pretty widely and we hope it
brings immunity in its wake a study last
week suggested herd immunity in
Stockholm could be achieved next month
and with an infection rate of 40% but
Sweden's experiment has not it seems
tempted other countries to copy it Boris
Johnson and Matt Hancock are inspired by
the testing intensive German model and
understandably so Germany has tested
about 3 million people for the virus and
it's tech approach explains how the
country has managed to keep its death
toll so low mass testing is also crucial
for Germany's reopening plan boss
restaurants and small shops can now take
customers again provided that staff wear
face masks and that people respect
social distancing rules the Bundesliga
will restart but by a munich Borussia
Dortmund and other clubs won't be
playing in crowded stadiums later this
month pupils will start going back to
schools even Germany strategy has at
times been held up by Britain as an
example of what not to do the UK is
judging things by the rates at which the
virus spreads the so called our number
the aim is to maintain it at below 1 so
the number of new infections Falls
although the are is not published daily
in Britain it is in Germany and a week
after Angela Merkel declared the
reopening of the country it has risen
from 0.65 to above 1 this was taken by a
Dominic Raab the foreign secretary as
proof or what happens to countries that
reopen too hastily but by whose
standards in Germany there is clear
support for faced reopening
unlike in Britain German authorities
aren't too alarmed by rises in the our
number which is in any case is subject
to a lot of assumptions guesswork and
regional variation instead Germans are
judging their approach to lock down by a
simply test the number of infections if
the number of weekly cases is higher
than 50 per 100,000 population in any
given area then the regulations will
tighten but only in that area this
brings us to an important aspect in the
question of ending lockdown regional
differences we're all used to seeing
virus crafts comparing Britain's
progress with say Spain or France but
this disguise is a crucial point
there are huge variations within
countries in the past week Bavaria has
averaged 195 new cases a day Mecklenburg
Western Pomerania however has recorded
only four per day the north of Italy was
horribly affected the South hardly at
all a quarter of all stock holders have
now had the virus according to official
estimates it's covered rate has been six
times that of Malmo one Regional Council
leader confessed that he had come to the
capital to try to catch the virus to
gain immunity in the US
Donald Trump has reduced to the status
of an onlooker cheering on the states
that are raised in lockdown there is
variety even within those states in
Florida restaurants are open except in
Miami in Palm Beach and South Dakota
businesses can reopen in counties that
are not hotspots for the virus
christening its governor says this
approach would put the power of
decision-making into the hands of the
people where it belongs
even my emanuelle McComb has given up on
his earlier idea of France taking a
national approach to lock down while the
reopening of schools is part of a
national plan many parts of France have
been given permission to come out of
lockdown faster than others they make up
what is called the Green Zone the 80 or
so de Partie mall where the virus isn't
circulating much
para cenar north-east however our a red
zone while per se ins no longer need to
fill in a document to leave their houses
they are still restricted they aren't
able to dine at the local bistros and
nor are the city's parks and gardens
open during this phase France wouldn't
be France if the pandemic didn't inspire
new ground attempts to engineer the
economy in typical top-down fashion the
French Minister of Labor has issued a
twenty page plan for new safety measures
at businesses big and small
adding to the 48 covered walk plays
guidelines that were introduced in late
April thanks to the government every
business owner now knows how to clean
the premises and improve workflow
management then there is the
technological response to the virus is
there an app for that and if not can we
make one France like Britain has
declined offers from Google and Apple to
build decentralized tracing apps instead
created its own national app stop copied
the government has promised that it will
be ready next month even though it
hasn't been fully tested yet the main
flaw is rather obvious if the virus can
spread through people who never develop
symptoms how will they be detected by
any app the French Assembly doesn't look
entirely comfortable about approving the
app just as in Belgium where the
government recently canceled plans for
digital tracing there are now strong
concerns in France that the app could
prefers a power grab deputies from both
the ruling party mccombs
republic on marsh and the opposition
assumes that people won't like having
big brother in the phone now that they
have been freed from their mandatory
confinement overall though local and
decentralized approaches do seem to work
better than big in big national efforts
there are cultural differences to
consider as well as the uneven spread of
the virus Evora isn't the same as Berlin
and Bruges isn't the same as Brussels
local authorities can move faster than
national governments when power is
dispersed rather than concentrated there
is better chance that successful
policies will be found and adopted in
places and that failures will be spotted
the reason Germany does so well with
testing is in part that it doesn't have
a centralized Health Service it has 16
strong state governments and below that
401 districts together with a strong
private medical sector since Berlin
isn't running the country's health care
system hospitals they don't have to wait
for Merkel or a reg tag committee to
scale up testing local authorities could
do that on their own and were able to
experiment a lot in setting up their
facilities for mass testing and German
states that were less quick off the
block could catch up by copying what
other states were doing the idea of a
nationally imposed lockdown grades with
many of Europe's regions a court in the
German state of Saarland for instance
ruled in late April that several of its
restrictions were unconstitutional
last month there were small
demonstrations in several German cities
where people were protesting against
restrictions on civil liberties it
became increasingly difficult to dismiss
such protesters as right-wing trolls
especially as petitions were also filed
and other state courts similar
rebellions are underway in Italy this
week for instance the government in
South Tyrol has allowed bars restaurants
and hairdressers to open up again
despite several warnings from Rome that
regions shouldn't allow restaurants to
have seated guests before June in Veneto
people can now sit down outdoors for
drink and at a bar and again against
Rome's instructions they can travel
freely within the region to take care of
second homes long body and several other
regions have warmed the national
government that if restrictions on shops
saloons and beaches aren't lifted next
week they will abolish them anyway
everywhere there is political posturing
many leaders find their opinion poll
ratings boosted by the crises some find
it difficult to wean themselves off
strongman politics hunger is Viktor
Orban has used the pandemic as an
opportunity to grab more
power and he isn't planning to hand it
back meanwhile Denmark's center-left
Prime Minister Metta Frederickson has
increased her party's ratings by 8
percent since early March and she would
like to maintain her Iron Lady image
Dane's she seems to think having joined
the firm smack of the government and
want more of it local political leaders
- are enjoying the spotlights Marcus Oda
the state premier of Bavaria has been
labeled deutschlands corona hardliner
and he is weighing for stronger national
influence set against him is Armin
Lockett the state leader of North
rhine-westphalia who is now the
frontrunner to take over the National
Party and succeed Merkel he has been
airing his frustration with national
lockdown policies for more than a month
Russia took a more liberal line then
Merkel and couldn't wait to rid the
country or to what he considered silly
restrictions in the end Russia and other
state premiers made it politically
impossible for Michael not to start
reopening the country where does all
this leave Britain staying in lockdown
maybe a crushingly expensive luxury but
at least it allows the opportunity to
learn from other countries about what
works and what doesn't if the UK wants
to recreate Germany's machinery of
testing it may need to consider how to
decentralize things and allow more
regional experiments but overall the
lesson is that any leaders seeking to
protect their economy in society will at
some point have to take the plunge
there are no certainties not enough
science no chance of avoiding risk but
when the time comes to break from the
lockdown like every country written will
be flying in a dog that was Frederick
Erickson now James Forsythe COBIT 19 has
been perhaps the biggest test of
governments worldwide since the 1940s
declares the government's come on paper
on the virus the fact that the following
paragraph proposes a rapid reengineering
of government structures and
institutions is telling it is an
implicit admission that the British
government machine is several important
areas fading this test
we argued about whether the UK has the
worst death toll in Europe risks
descending into statistical absurdity
until access mortality figures are known
it won't be possible to come to a
verdict but it's hard to argue with the
UK's are much better than France Spain
and Italy we have clearly done worse
than Germany and I'm Mars behind South
Korea Taiwan and Japan to put it another
way there'll be no international teams
coming to his country to learn how to
prepare for a pandemic this is all the
more shocking given that for some time a
pandemic has been at the top of a
national risk register the UK government
regarded itself as been one of the best
prepared in the world but it had been
preparing for an influenza pandemic
considering that covin 19 is the third
coronavirus outbreak the century after
saws and MERS this was an unacceptable
failure of imagination Britain has long
prided itself on its rolls-royce
government machine this crisis so has
exposed its limitations one Whitehall
veteran says that the 10 days leading up
to the 23rd and March well the nearest
the wiring of a state has come to a
collapse it wasn't just blowing a fuse
the motherboard was beginning to melt
down the lockdown has cost the state
centre stage it is paying the bulk of
the wages of seven and a half million
private-sector workers and offering cash
support loan guarantees and cheap credit
to businesses but as one Secretary of
State admits the government couldn't
have got through this crisis without the
private sector for instance that hadn't
been the food sources that many feared
there would be when supply chains began
to be disrupted when the government was
failing on testing private companies
stepped in to help it hit it's a hundred
thousand a day target this private
sector involvement is going to continue
to be crucial I am saying that key
figures in government believe his
country will need the capacity to carry
out half a million tests a day if the
lockdown is to be properly lifted but
others think 200,000 will be enough for
a comprehensive track and trace strategy
a hubris state belief in the ability of
a state to do it all lay behind the most
disastrous decision of his whole episode
the ending of testing and tracing early
in the outbreak ministers were told that
there wasn't the capacity to carry out
enough tests as the virus started
spreading but there could have been the
problem was of businesses universities
and researchers were not being asked for
help by public health England a more
collaborative approach has seen in
Germany would have allowed has seemed to
be increased at sufficient speed part of
difficulty was at public health England
craze in 2013 is an arm's length body
this means that while the sector
State for Health can remove its chair he
can't tell it what to do on a day-to-day
basis one result of the past amounts
will be these arms and bodies will lose
their autonomy in futures ministers will
be able to issue them with instructions
another body that is the subject of
March are is the Cabinet Office one of
its jobs this coordinate between various
players scientific advisory committee
stage the Department of Health and
Social Care public health England and
the rest of government according to
Whitehall sources is a struggle a first
blush this seems strange and is run by
marvel go regardez the Tories most
effective developmental minister in
Digos ability to run a department it's
one of the reasons Boris Johnson captain
in the cabinet despite their spectacular
option 2016 but only half of the Cabinet
Office answers to go the other half the
civil service fiefdom this must change
if government is to function better
Teresa's Mays time and number 10 made
this problem worse there used to be
three secretaries one covering economic
and domestic policy another national
security and a third EU and global
issues she merged into one
this is led to a lack of debate with him
white one hulking government says that
this issue has been compounded by
cabinets actually smart said well
staying on as National Security Advisor
they complain that in a well-functioning
system the National Security Adviser
would have challenged the cabinet's
extra non-sexy on the hawala decision
but that can't happen when the National
Security Adviser and the cabinet's
actually are the same person a breakup
of Simone's Empire looks inevitable
cabinet government has also been a
victim of a lockdown
even one hour the Prime Minister admits
everything is getting more fractious
mood of the outer cabinet everyone in
cabinet part from goes Matt Hancock
Ritchie student kendama Nate Robb is
turning rank rats but irritated see
decisions taken before the cabinet's met
they feel what their advice is being
ignored Ben Wallace the defense actually
stole allies did he often milites helped
to try and lessen the tragedy seen in
care homes
on one occasion last month Wallace wants
to join the morning coronavirus cook
which is more important than cabinet
meetings these days one member of the
cabinet who is always on the court
objected and said that he wasn't
comfortable the chatty wallets dialing
in the result with the defense actually
was not involved he has though been on
calls which have discussed the Armed
Forces role in the COBIT response but a
base in this country is also often about
whether we want big or small government
when what we really need is effective
government Britain has long flattened
itself but it leads the world and
administration but clover 19 has
highlighted how far from being true that
now is
the British state needs rewiring for the
21st century
if the system is not to meltdown
completely in the next crisis James
Forsythe and finally least a rough night
to my surprise what I miss most about
life before the lockdown are parties as
others pine for restaurants and theaters
I am longing for sticky floors and 4
a.m. Uber's give me plastic cups and
music so loud you feel it in your
kidneys Sylvia Plath wrote disparagingly
of the shrill tinsel gaiety of parties
with no purpose it's precisely that
shrillness and pointlessness that I'm
yearning for drunk young bodies cramming
together for no reason other than to be
close to one another at the weekend my
longing finally spilled over and I
decided to make do online I put on a
nice top and loaded my lashes with
mascara I'm spending the pandemic at my
parents house in the suburbs and while
they watched foils war in the
sitting-room I stood next door with my
laptop and third glass of champagne
cruising the internet for raves I
dropped by party on zoom' that had been
put on to raise money for the NHS there
was a DJ playing 90s heads and about 30
strangers and little squares on my
screen dancing away in their living
rooms I turned out the lights and began
to cut some shapes to imagining I was in
a club and someone had spilled vodka
orange down my top after a while I felt
a euphoric sense of goodwill to all
these strangers dancing together alone
on the aspects of city life that I've
been missing since the virus spread is
the routine presence of strangers now I
rarely see anyone I don't know well but
these virtual dance events thrust you
into countless bedrooms and kitchens
filled with people you will never see
again on zoom' you can get a good look
at your fellow attendees and I pause my
dancing to snoop one couple were
watching the party unfold impassively as
if it were the evening news a woman in a
sports bra was tossing her hair around
another window showed a Labrador being
stroked by someone off camera it was as
good a Saturday night as I've had since
the pandemic hit put it down to covert
induced anxiety or simple clumsiness
but I seem to be breaking things in the
moment the latest casualty was a mixing
bowl which I smashed on the kitchen
floor glass scattered everywhere and I
spent a hunch ten minutes with a dustpan
and brush trying to sort it all out
my mother advised that I vacuum but I
couldn't be bothered she pursed her lips
whine forward a few hours and I entered
the kitchen to chaos
my sister was groaning her foot gushing
blood
my mother was leaning over her expertly
tweezer in out a nugget of glass from
her skin I felt horribly contrite and
ran to get the vacuum cleaner but when I
came back both sister and mother were
crying with laughter having staged the
whole thing apparently Tabasco mixed
with ketchup makes the realistic fake
blood I vacuumed it's strange to be
publishing a book during a plague in my
novel out this week in no physical book
shops near you my widowed character ADA
gives a reading from her new poetry
collection she's nervous but it goes
well thanks to the virus I'm at least to
be spared the indignity a fewer people
turning up to a reading of mine than my
fictional characters the book is about
loneliness and the longing for community
two subjects have suddenly seemed fairly
central while publishers are wringing
their hands about the state of the
industry books feel more important than
ever
I'm currently inching through Hilary
mantel not the new one but her novel
about the French Revolution a place of
greater safety in 1770 she writes life
expectancy in France was 29 years
hangings were routine so were bread
riots however bad we think we have in it
life is a good deal better now than it
was much as I'm glad to have more time
to read I resent the pandemic for having
constricted conversation
the only tele people seem to be watching
as normal people the only topic they are
willing to discuss in depth is the
pandemic and its impact on them
monoculture is back I miss having
conversations in which plot and surprise
featured even before the crisis my
friends and I communicated largely by
sending one another meandering voice
messages recorded on whatsapp I
still receiving and sending them
throughout the day but no one has much
to report other than the vagaries of
their emotional life and how much they
are lusting after the jumpers in normal
people Norbit
Ernie boo these are just some of the
names of our new chicks christened by my
little sister people keep asking me
where they come from as though hopeful I
know of some underground hen railroad
where they can get their hands on
illicit chicks too we got them from
their mothers boringly when the birds
first hatch they didn't look like much
no fluff to speak of and creepily large
feet but they're becoming formidable
cute it's no use telling chicks to
social distance either the five of them
crowd together gaily pecking one another
and chattering about the day's events
life goes on but it might not for much
longer a red kite has noticed them and
is planing high above the yard where the
chickens live I'm inspired by that scene
in fantastic mr. Fox and they sit by the
coop in a raincoat with a rifle in my
lap till the danger passes that was lief
Arbuthnot's and this is the end of this
particular episode of spectator audio
reads we're still playing around with
his formats we're very grateful for any
feedback you might want to send in you
can email us at podcasts at spectator Co
dot uk' we always readers inbox and it's
always great to hear from our readers
and thank you for listening and thanks
to our producer Cindy
try four weeks of The Spectator
absolutely free and for this month only
you'll receive a spectator Wireless
phone charger